this episode is killing me guys and I
don't mean in a weird Gordon way so
we're gonna cut all the BS and get right
into it episode 8 starts with Gordon
you'll remember him as the prospective
buyer of Dale Lacey's home in episode 4
this is a flashback to when he taught in
Des Moines and he looks to be
interviewing one of his PhD candidates
they discussed two things of note
evolutionary psychology and humanism
referencing Aldous Huxley and Carl
Rogers two prominent humanists the key
principle of humanism being that a
person has control over their own
behavior that a person has freedom of
choice and is responsible for his own
self direction this would be a direct
contradiction to the events in the show
as it seems there have been many
instances where characters do not have
control over their own behavior
apparently this dude had sex with
Gordon's wife so he does what any
upstanding professor would do and bashes
his face in with a notepad this likely
resulted in him being fired hence gordon
and his wife's moved to castle rock
we're back in the scene from episode
four but this time it's from Gordon's
perspective you can make out a photo of
Dale and Martha Lacey in the background
as well as Dale's crow Mane's which
Gordon founded the freezer
Gordon stares at the pitcher of Castle
Lake the same area where Dale drove his
car off in episode one
check out the name of the moving company
out of dodge a reference to the
television show Gunsmoke in which the
term get out of Dodge was often told to
the villains and you get out of Dodge
Gordon puts a sign up for the Castle
Rock historic bed-and-breakfast a new
business to attract dark tourism where
he hopes to recreate murders in
exquisite detail
hence the mannequins for what it's worth
I tried checking out the website but
nothing came up here we see another
mannequin in the tub you're Lee similar
to the dead body we see in the same tub
in Episode two
Gordon's wife tells him she found the
key to the basement the basement that
Henry inquired about with Martha down
there she finds dozens of paintings of
the kid is this also the basement where
Henry was kept ages ago the ones we've
seen in his flashbacks we'll get to that
a bit later
Gordon paints one of his mannequins when
his wife comes in looking for some sexy
time she asks can't we just say it never
happened but it's clear he's still not
over her cheating in the next scene we
see the mannequin with an axe
through its head the first of many
mannequins Gordon hopes to transform
into murderous recreations of castle
rocks past we learned he did his PhD
paper on the BTK killer Dennis Rader BTK
standing for bind to torture and kill
the way in which Dennis murdered his 10
victims Gordon is clearly annoyed at his
establishments first lodgers they don't
seem to be interested in the B&B
experience rather they themselves are
looking for a secluded getaway to cheat
on their spouses and we know how Gordon
feels about cheaters at night Gordon
hears them having sex and leaves the
room his wife wakes up looking for him
and stumbles upon him having murdered
them this guy clearly has some rage
issues
is it possible Gordon is Gordie the
little boy we saw the kid watch in
episode 5 I went back and re-watch the
scene and heard something really crazy
and I'm gonna play it for you so listen
up right after a happy birthday you can
hear a weird sex moan did you hear it
okay that's a bad Castle Rock pun but
notice also the knife perhaps
foreshadowing what Gordon would do in
the future
Mollie wakes up experiencing the same
flashes that Henry has an anechoic
chamber we see a lot of stuff we've seen
before but I'll focus on the new pieces
notably the rope like that found in Dale
Lacey's garage the axe water heater the
kid acting shocked at what he sees and a
man holding a screwdriver who we've seen
flashes of in previous episodes this
likely indicates that this man is the
kid holding the screwdriver to get Henry
out of the cage you'll remember Dale AC
used a similar tool to build the cage
for the kid in the water tank Mollie
saves Henry from the chamber and as they
escape we see Odin's dead body stabbed
through the eye with one of the hot
pokers now we don't know if it was Willy
who did it or perhaps even Molly herself
molly has been known to be out of
control of her body from time to time
Molly drops Henry off he's starting to
realize that Molly can actually feel
what he's feeling
they make up Molly saying it's okay
because people have been calling me
crazy my whole life pretty ironic since
the last thing Henry said to her before
the chamber was you are [ __ ] crazy
Henry comes home and finds everything as
clean as a PO
the bloody mess of last night Ruth is
sleeping and after everything that
happened to her in the last episode it's
good to see her finally getting some
rest
Henry confronts the kid in the kitchen
remember he last dropped him off at
juniper Hill and doesn't know about the
escape Henry tells Wendell to go
upstairs and lock the door
the kid leads Henry to the body of
Allan's saying they need to dispose of
it to protect Ruth the kid has been
waiting for Henry for 27 years and it's
revealed that it was him who rescued
Henry from that basement but before
anything can be done Wendell calls the
police and the cops arrive Gordon
dismembers one of the bodies putting it
into pieces just like one of his
mannequins when Jackie arrives we hear
on the radio that the Juniper hill
patients lit their mattresses on fire at
the same time and that the suspect the
kid is still on the loose
Gordon's wife helps him with the body
perhaps her way of making it up to him
for cheating that's love ladies and
gentlemen Jacki Torrance arrives wanting
to check out castle rocks newest
attraction gordon remarks you know your
axes of course she would she's the niece
of Jack Torrance she's quickly ushered
out of the house while Jackie picks up
on their weird vibes she finds an odd
shaped ornament and what appears to be
blood so she does what any normal person
would do and licks it what's with these
people in this town licking things
Henry talks to Wendell about Allen's
body being discovered you'll notice a
book by Joseph Campbell goddess's on
display
Joseph Campbell is one of the greatest
academics on mythology if you want to
learn a bit more about him check out my
video on home alone in the heroes
journey
we learned that Wendell was afraid and
spent the night at the church
Henry goes to talk to Ruth who has
really lost her mind
she thinks Allen is still alive and that
she killed Matthew her husband not Alan
and perhaps she did in an alternate
timeline in a conversation with the
police they're treating the murderer as
if the kid did it
letting Ruth off the hook for now the
cop calls Henry the Black Death because
every time he comes around bad stuff
happens
Henry sends Wendell back to Boston
Wendell pleads for him to come with but
Henry has unsettled business to attend
to
Wendell says that he learned more about
his father and one day from his dementia
ridden grandmother than from his own
father in his entire life a bird smashes
into the bus just like one did in
episode
six leading me to believe either the
skismo or Henry is causing these freak
disturbances in an interesting twist
Wendell begins to hear the skismo
extremely loud no less Henry and Molly
discussed his encounter with the kid and
he inquires about the new owners of Dale
Lacey's home Molly tells him Martha
couldn't find the key probably because
she was blind henry breaks into the lacy
basement and you'll notice the same type
of brickwork like Henry saw in his
flashbacks I'm not a hundred percent
sold that this is the same basement but
it's a possibility
upstairs Henry finds a room filled with
Dale Lacey's paintings of the kid he
takes them out of their frames noting
different dates he locks on the painting
you'll recognize from his flashback in
the anechoic chamber it's dated 1991 the
same year the kid was captured by Dale
and that young Henry disappeared they're
both wearing the same striped shirt
perhaps leading us to believe that the
kid is Henry in an alternate universe
Molly begins to see more visions young
Henry chasing him in the forests what
appears to be the back side of the kid a
bloody knife that we saw briefly in the
anechoic chamber and herself in the
forest is that Odin behind her finally
we see her covered in blood a figure
walks over her likely the kid to deal
with these visions she downs four pills
more than her usual half of one
Henry snaps photos of the paintings when
he's caught by Gordon he gets up to
leave when he stabbed by Gordon's wife a
scuffle ensues in which Gordon is
stabbed and the wife as well Henry runs
and gets in his car but is attacked by
Gordon and it looks like Gordon is about
to win when Jackie Torrance saves the
day with an axe I guess good axe work
runs in the family
Molly swears on the road high from the
insane amount of drugs she's just taken
Wendell gets off the bus at a stop
called Jerusalem's lon which some of you
King fans may recall from Salem's Lot
looks like he's on his way back home
note that Jerusalem was also the town
where Jesus was both crucified and
resurrected the police arrive at Dale
Lacey's and Jackie explains how she came
to save Henry
is it possible she has some form of The
Shining which led her back to him she
also says I wasn't myself anymore was
someone controlling her remember Jackie
in the kid likely touched way
back in Episode five there's even a
theory that they had sex Mali arrives
home to find the kid waiting for her on
the stairs she asked where Henry is and
he says I don't think he's ready yet you
could help me because you know me Henry
gets a call from Reverend Appleton
saying that her mom came in asking him
Alan was alive or dead she seemed
confused but ran off is she seen him
alive in an alternate universe or is it
just her dementia he rushes off to her
evading police and now making him ever
more suspicious in the string of murders
that keep happening the police even
referred to him as a suspect back with
Mollie the kid is able to tell her about
her past where all the things in the
house used to be how she painted her
fingernails with wite-out and Sean her
flashlight up the hill she asks how he
knows to which he replies I was there
this could be possible to know if the
kid was some sort of alternate universe
Henry it starts to snow as the two look
out the window and every time it snowed
so far in the show it's been a dream so
keep that in mind
the shocking reveal at the end comes
when the kid says out there in the woods
that's where you died now this could be
a few things that she's already dead
hence why the kid says she's ready as
opposed to why Henry isn't the idea here
being that Molly swerved off the road
when she was high on vicodin and other
theories that she died in the alternate
universe where the kid is from and that
the turkey vultures flying over pucks
body that Roo season episode seven are
actually hovering over Molly's also know
that what she's wearing in the car is
not the same as what she's seen wearing
in the flashback of her covered in blood
in the forest so there are still a bunch
of unanswered questions and with just
two episodes left I don't know how
they're gonna answer them all the next
episode is called Henry Deaver where
we'll likely learn who or what exactly
Henry is and the pieces should start
falling into place as always if you
liked this video make sure to LIKE and
subscribe leave your theories below I
love to read them and stay tuned every
Thursday for more castle rock breakdowns
see you then